john hein was telling me he's not even
impressed by jd's card collection
he gave it a four he gave it a four out
of ten he goes it's not even good he
doesn't even know anything he doesn't
know anything jd gets very defensive
about this like he's the authority when
it comes to i am not an authority i just
know what i have all right jd has almost
okay he's logged almost 6 000 cards in
the database at this point wow
he's got 31 tiger woods cards okay well
yeah i got a i found a set of cards so
that's
30 of them but jd looks at this as an
investment he believes that over time it
will grow in value
cash in on it no i have the card in the
database these are cards i you know when
i was a kid growing up i just wanted to
write you what i had and log them more
for that reason john stop getting into
my head i know what there are some for
sure that might be an event but that's
not why i'm doing it for the most part
but what are you doing it for i mean it
makes me happy i like seeing some of
them and you know some of them are on
display right behind jd yeah i have all
of these joe burrow cards since football
season i put joe burrow and bengals cars
back there and what'd you do you and you
put them in a little frame
uh well no some have been graded already
so by grading company so they they put
them in there
but but howard he takes this attitude
like i show him like an old card i have
and he's like oh the corners are bent
and it's like this it's not worth
anything he he just takes his elitist
attitude towards coach you know that's
just with you john i'm trying to help
you out too
in my mind there's a guy who owns a card
company
he could print out a million of these
cards he's controlling the guy who owns
the card companies controlling the
market if he wants to have 50 000 tiger
woods cards he can just print i mean
that's what the big thing is now
uh with cards is they're doing them
there's some are being given serial
numbers so they only you know there's
only
so many made out of 50 you know
you know 50 of a certain card was made
what's the best card you have oh i don't
uh i mean the tiger woods one is pretty
good
uh how much has it appreciated since you
bought it well listen
i guarantee i gotta even get 70 bucks
for it
well and i
could
these are long-term investments why not
invest in a house
well i am doing that how much money do
you think you've spent on cards
if you got six thousand cards oh over oh
well hold on overall you know overall i
got when i was a kid you think it's ten
thousand bucks no i don't think it's
quite that much john what has he got
over time yeah i think he spent at least
ten thousand dollars yeah over time sure
recently you know what he could do he
could he could take the cards
and glue them together into the shape of
a house and then live in the cars i'm
with you howard i tell them like
financially this isn't going to do it
for you i'm not doing it financially
that's great but if you think you're
going to make like this big killing on
your 28 ken griffey jr cards or whatever
other crappy cincinnati red you got it's
just not gonna work hit him with a high
all right enough of jd i mean i don't
mean to that was fascinating though oh
yeah thanks for the look into your
private life
john keep tabs on him
yeah he is always howard